community brighton 8 news now is
sponsored by our community pride
partners finley automotive group
southwest medical part of optum care and
silver state schools credit union
finley automotive group the sponsors of
this next segment want to introduce you
to their brand new volvo facility rocky
stop by to check it out
[Music]
we all love that fresh car smell but in
this case this is fresh car dealership
right right tyler absolutely welcome to
the brand new findlay volvo this is our
new facility that we built on uh we're
on the beltway between rainbow and jones
and uh we when we got the volvo
franchise in 2017 our
ideal our dream was to build them a
brand new facility and so this is the
culmination of that dream we're lined up
here at findlay chevrolet finley's
subaru of las vegas finley's jaguar land
rover las vegas all lined up in a row
here and we're really really proud of
this city and we're glad to invest
because we're so positive on the future
of volvo and the future of las vegas so
we're just really excited about our
brand new lovely facility it is
beautiful in here and volvo is known to
be a very safe vehicle but now the
future is going all electric right yeah
absolutely it is so you know what i'd
like to introduce you to jim digiulio
he's our general manager here at finley
volvo let him tell you a little bit more
about that jim it is nice to finally
meet you this does not look like any
other car shop i've ever been in it is
not and we really appreciate that when
you were with tyler earlier you had
mentioned volvo's renown for safety
which is absolutely one of the pillars
of our brand and that in 1959 as a
matter of fact we invented the
three-point seat belt and a lot of
people don't realize that the engineer
nils bolin is responsible for saving
over a million lives with the invention
of the three-point seat belt but as you
mentioned earlier we're also
transitioning into a technology company
into an ev company so there are some
things that we did in the workshop that
are really cool that add efficiency and
make your service experience a lot
better for instance this whole side of
the shop here is built to handle full
electric vehicles as we transition into
that space as not only an industry but
as a brand because by 2030 will be a
full electric brand but in addition to
that what we did is we set up all of our
technician workstations so that we can
have two technicians working on a car at
the same time so if your car needs
brakes for instance i can get your pads
and rotors done in less than 30 minutes
get you out of here in an hour with the
wash which is a huge time saver and it
really addresses one of the holes that
we found in the car industry which is
sometimes that service frustration about
the length of time that it takes and the
calls into the dealership and things of
this nature so we really try hard we
schedule technicians on their time to a
specific technician much like you would
a dentist or a doctor's appointment and
we have the technician ready and waiting
for you when you arrive jim this is
volvo's very first full electric vehicle
that's right yeah this is the xc40
recharge we spoke about our transition
to fully electrified and this is our
first step into that venture it's a
really really exciting product it has
408 horsepower making it a ton of fun to
drive but what's even cooler about this
car is as we all transition into wanting
our cell phones to be uh the car to be
an extension of our cell phone this is
the first car sold with the google
in-car operating system why did you tell
the car what you wanted to do
okay hey google change the temperature
to 68 degrees
all right changing the temperature to 68
degrees
[Music]
thank you findlay automotive group for
sponsoring this segment check out
findlay volvo cars las vegas on roy horn
way you can also give them a call for
more information at 888-558-2114
or head to findlayvolvocarslv.com